ah stupid thing come on that's I'll go
with that
sure why not alright hi everybody hope
everyone's doing okay this evening
I am a sweaty mess because I have been
out in my yard digging a flowerbed which
will have a lovely result but is not a
fun process to engage in this is ticking
me off
I read set this thing a little bit ago
and I can't get it to straighten out the
way I want it to Hey no not nothing's
agreeing with me today that's just how
it's going hi hi Cara uh actually open
midnight for one of these for once Oh
Bailey I'm sorry I'm keeping you up so
late but thank you very much for joining
allowed to use well honor
so yeah the the title of the livestream
adulting sucks cuz yeah it just kind of
does I don't really have much of a plan
or a theme here we'll talk about stuff
as it comes up alright this is driving
me nuts
why sorry hang on this is
I'm gonna do that that's better
all right I felt like the camera was
pointed at my crotch and it was really
bothering me generally if you want that
view you got to pay me more ah adulting
is overrated it's not it's not just that
adulting is overrated it's it's a
freakin jail sentence ah hey I got some
great news they're remaking the lost old
Doctor Who episode in that in animation
format which one there's a handful left
[Music]
can we just agree that being adults and
kids both suck in different ways and
being a teenager I get the worst of both
worlds sure yeah I'll go with that
look when I say adult things sucks I'm
I'm not one of those people's gonna be
like you kids you got it easy no be kid
sucks too just in a different way and
when you become an adult you find
yourself oddly nostalgic for the ways in
which being a kid sucked as opposed to
being in adults like but again that's
not me saying that you've got it easier
just different I've just read it on my
rayon hey there Tracy thanks so much
oh how much more springing off of you'd
have to pay me more for the for the
crotch shots sorry you left yourself
open there I did a little bit I mean if
you want to get an idea of what folks
see when I'm paid um head on over to the
very wild Instagram and the latest
picture that went up there for my show
this past Friday so there you go y'all
have a homework assignment love the
glasses yeah I like these uh I like
these glasses a lot alright so I did
take like last time but I'm gonna try
and make a habit of this excuse me I did
take questions from the discord
so the first one of those that I have is
I would like to hear your take on
parenting if you are so inclined boy
that's broad um I don't talk about
parenting a heck of a lot um I think
largely because I don't presume that I'm
better at it than anybody else is um and
I don't I don't talk about it a ton here
just because I have a very high degree
of concern and respect for my you know
my kids privacy you know I talking of
the people if they pay attention they
they should know I have a daughter she's
seven I'll leave it at that pretty sure
I've never actually even said her name
on here and I that's intentional but I
mean the big thing for me is because her
mother and I aren't together anymore but
one of the things that has been very
grateful and has made the split um
[Music]
easier for like a better word is that
we've always been on the same page in
terms of parenting and where boundaries
should be set and when something goes
wrong even like when it's because
strictly speaking when she's with me her
mother's responsibility when she's with
her stung my responsibility but if
something is going wrong and we're like
and either one of us either myself or
her are kind of like ah I feel like I'm
up against the wall like we'll get in
touch like usually over text be like
okay look this is what's going on this
is what I'm thinking tell me if I'm
crazy or if you have a better suggestion
and we're we have a good enough
relationship that we're okay to do that
and I think that makes life a lot easier
are you enjoying Stupak most popular
content week for 10,000 subscribers I
think it's great yeah anyone who doesn't
follows to bagful he is um yeah he's
having a bit of fun this week to mark
10,000 subscribers as he as he does his
version of clickbait it's um it's a
thing
are you closely following this year's
comic-con nope the thing is I actually I
feel like in a couple of years San Diego
comic-con is gonna go the way that III
is heading because I think more and more
the the people who used to do huge
announcements at comic-con
are realizing they don't need that stage
they don't need that platform I mean who
are the you know the big players at
comic-con in terms of announcements or
whatnot
oh thank you very much Dorian um you
know Marvel Star Wars Star Wars gets its
own celebration Marvel gets covered now
when Disney does d23 or whatever the
heck it is DC and Warner Brothers they
haven't really set up their own things
but like the number of these places that
like need the stage they don't and I
think they're realizing that um that
said it's not like it's irrelevant yet
but I think it's it's hit its peak in
terms of size and relevance and it's all
gonna be downhill from here as far as
I'm concerned um and you know San Diego
comic-con specifically is something that
like I've known interesting going to I
do want to get to more cons we're gonna
be going to terrific on next month
little is very excited about that but
like something the size of San Diego I'm
just like this doesn't need to exist not
in the digital age you know d3 is d23 is
soon - yeah and that's where I expect
Disney to make most of their major
relevant announcements like maybe
they'll trot out some specific actors
onto the stage at Comic Con um clarify
some things that you know give more
details of things that were announced at
d23 I don't think they're doing the big
announcements at Comic Con like if they
Marvel owned it owned Comic Con for
years and they don't they don't need to
defend their crown or anything there's
nothing to prove anymore this is more of
an assumption than a question
oh dang it it wandered off hang on let
me back up there's more of an assumption
link question I was one of your favorite
commenter seconds Billy here midnight
yeah review uh nothin I don't hold a
grudge Froy you did I saw what you did I
did put a stop to it but I um like I
know I get why you did it's okay you're
a great person and for whom jeez thank
you Alex that is that is a bold
statement and I'll take it
someone at the apartment complex said my
humor reminds her of Donna and dr. who
she's a Whovian well then that Donna is
a great compliment indeed I have um I
have a friend I have a burlesque friend
who Liz and I are desperately trying to
get her at least enough into Doctor Who
to see Donna cuz she looks a lot like
Donna and like ever since I met her I've
kind of been like I wish you were in
Doctor Who cuz you would do an awesome
like burlesque number is Donna and it
would be amazing just kind of got
Donna's personality a little bit to
Rose's mom
Martha's mom or Donna's mom Oh poof I
think like if I were gonna pick who I
was gonna be stuck with as a mother and
that's the basis I'm gonna be because
like broadly speaking in terms of who I
prefer to see on the show I guess
Donna's mom I think was usually better
written and better used but if one of
them was gonna be my mom I'd probably
opt for I probably out for Jackie roses
mom because as much as she could be a
bit irritating she was also probably the
most easygoing and least judgmental how
about those three kiss kiss marry or sex
oh that's the nonviolent version uh-huh
I'm glad that that exists because the
the usual shag marry kill
I always felt a little no wrong to me
have you seen any other word from
Katherine tape I've seen a little bit of
like her sketch comedy it's not really
my bag
I mean she's fine but um I haven't seen
a ton outside of that Oh Caroline best
of luck with that hi there
the word shagged sounds weird to me
coming from an American accent well the
thing is if I use the term that's
usually used in the American version of
that this video gets demonetised when I
archive it so you know that is what it's
what I opted for although it's it's
funny I actually mentioned this
podcaster and the secret of roan inish
review but the Andrew Leyland I'll right
into his podcasts and I will write
British slang into into the into my
email replies just because I love
hearing him say it and like I'd it's not
things that I would say casually in
conversation I don't say that
something's bollocks day to day but I'll
absolutely write it in my feed back to
him because I love hearing him say it I
and he is in fact British so there you
go which Doctor Who convenient had the
more sad ending Donna say yeah no it's
Donna
um so going back to the discord really
quick what was the first time you
realized you were an adult oh boy if I'm
what passes for an adulthood we are we
are all in trouble
um I don't know if there was a light
bulb moment but I don't think I really
truly started to properly feel like an
adult until my daughter was born that
that was
terrifying in a oh crap I need to stop
messing around and figure crap out kind
of way cuz somebody else is super
dependent on me have you ever watched
daredevil on Netflix I have I did a did
a review for season 3 I'm after that
came out I don't I don't think I have
reviews up for seasons 1 & 2 I like
season 1 a lot I did not like season 2
very much at all
raspberries are in season now I know
they're delicious love that shirt yeah
oh sure I'll shout this out actually
this is um there's a local guy to me um
he I usually see him at things like the
the Vermont Renaissance Fair this is VT
Celtic he comes up with these designs
and these shirts I've gotten like things
like this for other people though I
think my my mother gave me this one but
I like his designs a lot they're really
cool and it may stream anyone my
expertise yeah animate like I enjoy and
I made to a degree but like I'm very
careful about who I say that around cuz
then I'll get people just start throwing
anime titles at me and I'll be like
don't watch it don't watch it never
heard of it to watch oh I I end up
feeling unworthy of call myself an anime
fan pretty quick Jessica Joe's basically
followed the same pattern as daredevil
and stranger things he's one great
season to make wrap and season three
decent I hope so
I've still only done the one episode of
Jessica Jones I do need to get back to
it that said like I'm this I'm not
planning to add this live stream run
long the way the last few have because I
am up to my neck in editing that I'm
trying to get done cuz
I've got I've got a couple of videos
left that I really want done in time to
go out this month that are editing heavy
have you seen dimensions in time or the
five doctors I have seen the five
doctors I have not seen dimensions in
time that was actually so the review I
did the past weekend of the curse of
fatal death that that was a topic that
was voted on by the patreon supporters
so that I basically gave them a list of
what I considered to be Doctor Who
oddities and it was scream of the
schalke curse of fatal death and
dimensions in time I'm I've had a fourth
one I can't remember now but um and they
opted for curse of fatal death but like
I plan to get around to all this stuff
eventually someday maybe any thoughts on
the announcement that Tycho OTT is
writing and directing Thor for yes I
have one very important thought the
reason is assigned to Thor four is
because the Akira adaptation and
live-action stalled and that is a
glorious thing yes so I'm very happy
more so about the movie he's now not
making than the one he actually is but
you know there you go
when are you going to be on radio Mon
das I'm actually talking with ace
creeper we're trying to work that out
it's his schedules very open
right now mine isn't so you know it's
logistics like it always is have you
watched Doom Patrol I haven't I would
like to but I have not I jump back to
the discord real quick is it wrong that
as an adult I still want to go to work
dressed as bad um I don't think so that
makes sense to me I mean why wouldn't
you just yeah I just see co-workers
coming up to what are you doing on
Batman I am the knight so let's see um
one other I'll get here so I don't fall
behind on these what is your take on the
whole storm area 51 thing I actually
don't know what's going on there like I
kind of saw like some headlines or
whatnot but I don't I don't know wha so
I don't have an opinion cuz I don't know
enough about what's going on one more
thing
so I didn't reply you said you were
reviewing you said you reviewing
children of Earth as a possibility I'd
be really interested in hearing your
thoughts on that I would I would like to
revisit that certainly in terms of
Torchwood I am much more interested in
talking about children of earth than any
other part of Torchwood because I really
liked nobody heard that
children of Earth and I the the rest of
Torchwood
I am very mixed on part of me I'm just
pouring myself some water but I really
did like children of earth and part of
the reason I don't want to talk about
the rest of Torchwood is it would
require me to watch
the rest of Torchwood but children of
Earth can pretty much be seen in
isolation so I'm certainly more game for
that I don't have a space for it on the
docket yet as it stands but I mean one
of these days
I still can't rewatch children of Earth
it's amazing but very painful television
yeah it's not gentle children of Earth
is yeah here's a big part of what I like
about children of Earth especially
compared to some other episodes of
Torchwood children of Earth is
legitimately mature and adult as opposed
to the superficially mature an adult
that Torchwood usually was in his first
two seasons so like something like its
second episode which is day one which I
hate I hate that episode so much it is
so bad um written by Chris Chibnall but
I'm sure that's a coincidence
that was a low blow I'm sorry but um
that episode is just they take every
opportunity to swear they have as
graphic a sex scene as they could get
away with having they have sex be like a
major plot point it is superficially
mature whereas children of Earth is
mature and adult because it is dealing
with subject matter and ideas and themes
and consequences that you wouldn't want
a child to watch not because of like Oh
blood or breasts but because know these
concepts would mess somebody up and that
is what I like about it it shows a real
evolution of the show at that point in
time we went from watered soda I don't
know what you're talking about
capaldis character decisions and
children work I mean there's there's a
lot of tough a lot of tough stuff in
that and I haven't rewatched it um since
its aired so heck it messed me up and
I'm an adult I can't imagine what it
would do to a child yeah that's kind of
my point because like I can and some
people might consider this bad pairing
bad parenting but like I saw from a
fairly young age I saw um the movie
Trading Places which is a Dan Aykroyd
Eddie Murphy movie and that movie has
sweary f-bombs get dropped and nudity
but my mother didn't care because she
knew that I knew not to repeat those
words and my mother I could never had a
hang-up on nudity there's no actual sex
scenes of the movie but she was okay
with that because the basic premise was
something that could be enjoyed at any
age it was just the trappings that were
adult and that's another way that I feel
about a lot of stuff like the more
juvenile elements in early Torchwood as
opposed to something that is
fundamentally at its core it's very
conceptual seed you would not want that
near a kid thank you very much
princess best moment in Doctor Who movie
96 ah for me it's just this for me the
best moment is very small and it's when
the the doctor and grace I think it's
crazy um she they get pulled over by a
Oh ace creepers actually in the chat
awesome um but anyways they get pulled
over by a by a cop and the cop says your
friends British and the doctor goes am i
oh yes I suppose I am like I don't know
what it is there's something about that
moment is like is Oh
it's presented this oh I never thought
of it that way sort of thing and I
really like that from Hawaii but I love
that moment ah my cousin showed me
child's play when I was eight messed me
up
uh-huh I mean I've dedicated a video to
stuff that you know freaks me out and
not a ton of it was from childhood the
one that was though was Dark Crystal the
Skeksis Emperor because he dies early on
in the opening and he just looked so
sick like so rotting and his breathing
was this this harsh little - oh yeah
that creeped me out that I kind of
freaked me out as a kid and it still
like gives me the good just the
heebie-jeebies even now
saw Kerry hat six loved it yeah I mean
it's funny way but you people can be
okay with recently I saw the term and
the Princess Bride both great films they
are I should have put this on my
controversial opinions list Terminator
one is way better than Terminator 2 that
is not saying Terminator 2 is bad just
that the first one is much much better
the Skeksis were scary as a race
shudders even now I am really excited
for the the Dark Crystal thing that's
coming to Netflix mm-hmm
favorite sonic um I mean in terms of
like seeing it on the show I think I'm
partial to Elevens I like the you know
the feature of it um in terms of the
ones I actually have it they actually
like compiled these best my favorite
part of this is talking about the Doctor
Who movie my favorite part oh good an
excuse me was Eric Roberts he was by far
the best master okay okay I'll stop with
these shenanigans Oh whoo he's scared me
there I kind of like but you had a no
I'm sorry good say with a straight face
moment that was kind of it was kind of
awesome controversial opinion palpable
palp
oh okay so Palpatine I think
autocorrects got you there Palpatine in
Episode nine isn't the worst thing ever
and I'm excited to see how it plays out
how it ties the trilogy's together
whether or not the idea of Palpatine
coming back in Episode nine which I hate
conceptually I really really really
really really really hate it um we'll
see how it gets executed but whether or
not you think that's a bad thing has a
lot to do with what you like about Star
Wars and sort of your feelings on the
thing as a whole up till now and I'm
perfectly willing to accept that people
with different perspectives on the
series as a whole won't have the issues
that I have with it I freaking hate it
though
what doctor team up would you want to
see on screen and would you like a story
where everything is kind of normal the
doctor just looks for trouble without
finding it is we kind of had that I was
twice upon a time the doctor was so sure
he'd found trouble but he didn't there
was nothing wrong with what was going on
which was one of the reasons I like that
story actually um but an emperor
palpable but um as far as your first
question doctor team up I'm assuming you
mean like which versions of the doctor
paired with himself or themself
themselves I still getting used to that
um I I kind of I mean it's not possible
now but like just conceptually I kind of
like to see 12 and - Capaldi and
Troughton cuz I think
Traut not constantly but every now and
that would you something that would
really get on Capaldi's nerves and just
the that the eyebrow glare of death I
I'd like to see that you need to watch
dimensions in time it's trash that's
what I've heard that's yeah that's gonna
be an interesting thing have you seen
the Jody the show gentleman Jack no I've
heard of it
I haven't seen it adulting of the Daleks
um I'm going back to the discord I still
don't feel like an adult really as I'm
living with my dad to take care of him
after a stroke it's funny how um I don't
know if it's the case in other countries
it's certainly the case in the u.s. that
there is this perception that if you are
living with your parents regardless of
circumstances that it is somehow
invalidating of you
or autonomy I guess um or your status as
a grown-up but I don't really think
that's the that's the Khazar I kind of
wish we'd shake that off as a culture
especially if like you're there because
you're helping you know I think that
that that's a good thing you're doing to
be frank is it a causal of geeks
livestream without something of the
Daleks nope no it is not there's a great
five minute audio drama where to want
where to wanders into twelve was TARDIS
by accident they have a great dialing
about how twelves going through a
midlife crisis he kind of is we just one
of the reasons I really love twelve I
love that he's kind of got the the aging
rock star thing going um by his second
series at least um I really do I like I
agree and that's part of why I love him
I dig series nine with with a few very
specific episodes accepted
I do like series nine as well series
tens better but I do like series nine
have you watched the Sarah Jane
Adventures I need to add that one to the
list of permanent drinking questions
because he gets asked almost every time
I think I've seen I've seen all of I
think the first two series of that it's
been a long time though and not a lot
really stuck in my head and I think a
lot of that just has to do with frankly
I was older than the target demographic
which doesn't makes it make it bad it
just means it wasn't meant for me and I
enjoyed it about as much as somebody who
it wasn't designed to appeal to was ever
gonna enjoy it
have you watched years and years yet if
so thoughts I haven't I don't have HBO
anymore I got rid of it after Game of
Thrones and I've heard yours is very
good a buzzard is very depressing
which makes me kinda
want him to take the plunge if you'll
forgive me a double thing of the Daleks
yes gave I thought whoa a whole lot of
stuff going on here hold on
now fallen behind um how you doing
agreed that the idea of an adult living
with family is stupid that is so old hat
and overrated yeah yeah it really is is
this question going to end up as a
permanent drinking question the question
of whether or not a question is a
drinking question I'll think about it I
stopped watching Torchwood oh dang it
this thing is being stupid on me sorry
hang on I stopped watching Torchwood
after children of Earth never gonna
watch Miracle Day children of Earth is a
satisfying enough ending and it leads
off and I see into Jack's final apparent
story end of time yeah I still haven't
seen Miracle Day um
because like when I saw how tected the
reaction was it kind of made me go oh
maybe I'll just maybe I'll just leave it
and I haven't I haven't gone back and
caught up on it what do you preferred
pronouns what type of music do you
listen to okay it's not fair when I know
you know the drinking questions and
you're doing it on purpose that having
been said refreshing just got in what
are you hopes fourth or four I don't
have specific hopes my my reaction was
based more off the movie it meant that I
quote et wasn't going to make a Akira
cuz that movie should not happen how
about the music video for terminator 2
Guns N'Roses song I love Axl Rose waste
of ammo I don't think I've ever seen
that actually Miracle Day is in his van
as some people say it is it has its
moments I mean like the impression I got
with Miracle Day wasn't necessarily that
it was inherently some awful thing but
that it was such a step down from
children of Earth that even if it still
had merit
people considered it a letdown I sipped
my water what is that other movie a
lizard a Taika Waititi was tied to the
live-action American remake of Akira and
it stalled and that's what he's doing
Thor because live-action Akira
bad idea especially in American
live-action Akira
very very very very bad idea have you
ever done script writing yeah yeah I
wrote a script um I mean like aside from
obviously like writing my own shorts for
when this you know Bagon started this
channel I I did actually write a script
for a friend of mine who I ro script for
a ghost movie and they started shooting
it but then things stalled and like a
whole bunch the actors were college
students then they aged out of the part
or finished college and moved away or
whatever so like if that ever gets shot
they got that to start over from scratch
I'm not expecting it to ever happen but
yeah yeah I've written I've written
screen stuff is there any case when
you're not against remakes no but I'm
always very skeptical of them and like
my issues for Akira are twofold first is
I've got my inherent issue with animated
films being remade in live-action which
is I feel it inherently undermines the
value of animation as an art form
because it reinforces the idea that the
real movie is live-action and that's
that noise but beyond that Akira is so
embedded in Japanese culture and way of
thinking and I don't just mean because
it said in Neo Tokyo I mean the cultural
background of the fact that this story
takes place
and it's in a society in a country that
had nuclear bombs dropped on it is kind
of the entire freaking point and if you
remake it and set it anywhere else you
lose a massive part of them of the
cultural and historical context in which
the thing even exists in the first place
now let me also be clear if it ever gets
made I am open to the possibility that
it may in fact work you can have stories
that are deeply embedded in a specific
culture and if you deal with them
carefully Transplant them to another
culture my go-to example of that is the
departing which is a remake of Infernal
Affairs now Infernal Affairs was a film
very much entrenched in its and the
culture came from because it was about
triads and you know that whole organized
crime culture but when it was
transplanted over to the US and set in
Boston they restructured it from the
ground up to reflect the American
equivalent of that it was reworked
pretty heavily while keeping the same
core concept of mole in the police mole
in the in the mob so it can work but my
problem is ninety nine times out of a
hundred when a studio remakes a film
they are just banking on the name and
the built in name recognition then they
don't put the care in that is required
to remove something from the cultural
context of which was made and inject the
cultural context for which you're now
presenting it when that happens it is
amazing but that is such a minority of
times my default is gonna be skepticism
I'm actually trying to get into script
writing but I feel like I don't really
know where to start with developing my
central idea and do a full first draft
script well I mean the first thing
Bailey is that I would say is is this
something that you yourself are gonna
Shepherd as a film because to put it
very simply
unlike basically almost any other form
of writing unless you are script writing
is somebody that doesn't make it the
best unproduced scripts and whatnot but
simply put unless you have been paired
with being a director a producer
somebody who's gonna actually translate
it then you're kind of just shouting
into the void now that said that's not
me to discourage you trying to write a
script you want to write a script write
a script but just understand that until
you put it in there unless you yourself
intend to develop it or until you put it
in the hands of someone who actually
will shoot it then it's basically just a
writing exercise that you're engaging in
and there's still value in that but do
not expect it to go anywhere despite
dimma predicting and in quite a cynical
manner actually found Mark Gatiss
brigadiere twist quite heartwarming and
sweet favorite part of the story that I
didn't really like I thought did
actually work pretty well do you think
less of the Timelords would have been
better if the master have remained in
power and then season four would have
been him on earth first is Jefferson the
Daleks I never really thought about that
I'm not sure it would have been better
would have been interesting I'm starting
University in September studying a
degree in what is basically film
photography and media it could
definitely be a possibility okay yeah so
yeah I mean if you're going to
university that is gonna pair you up so
what I would say is start with a short
script start with a 15 to 20 minutes
short and and partner up with somebody
in the directing program at the
University so that you can get a feel
for the rhythm of it and get a feel for
it cuz this is the big thing before how
what you what is going to be changed by
whoever shoots it cuz the worst thing
that you can do if you have an interest
in screenwriting is get over the attach
to your vision of it cuz if you're not
the one shooting it whatever you
envision is not what's gonna happen I
mean it's the same good playwriting as
well I had a short play
I had a 10-minute play that got into a
festival a couple years ago and I went
and in like as part of that it got
performed and I went and I watched it
and I really really hated it because
very specifically one of the actors did
the choices he made in playing the part
in one of the parts that I wrote was so
antithetical to what I'd had in mind
that I absolutely hated it but the thing
was I wrote and it was very direct very
deliberately because I've had an
interest in acting I wrote it in such a
way that it was interpretable because if
you over specify in a either a
screenplay or a stage play exactly how
something is to be written
you are handcuffing your actors no
something I ran into with the play
that's actually that I've actually
self-published under very wild that one
of the earliest revisions I did after
having a reading of it was to remove a
bunch of things that were dictating how
the actors should be reading lines like
like I was using ellipses to indicate
pauses and one of the first pieces of
feedback I got was I really feel like I
don't get to decide how this line
reading is because you've told me where
all the pauses is I'm okay I need to
only do that if it's super important but
if it's just what it sounds like in my
head I need to take that out that needs
to be out of my power and into the power
of someone else which is the hardest
thing to sort of wrap your head around
to you if you're doing either script or
stage writing is that whatever you write
once it's in somebody else's hands
they're gonna do their own thing with it
for better or worse see The Shining
written by Stephen King but directed by
Stanley Kubrick gotta go have a fabulous
night see you Donna thank you very much
I don't know why I am giving script and
screenwriting advice I haven't written
anything that's actually like gotten
professionally performed or shot why did
don't listen to me I don't actually have
good advice to give Who am I
have you seen pose I have not pair of
sonic sunglasses or a sonic trowel I'll
take the sunglasses I like the sonic
sunglasses there's an unpopular opinion
for you Christopher Walken plays my
namesake be the angel Gabriel who would
you want to play your namesake oh there
was already a very cool person playing
my name's sake which is Daniel day-lewis
plays my namesake and let's see who the
first person who can name the movie is
so let's see is it unrealistic to want
to be a scriptwriter and director
because the thought of my vision getting
changed has occurred to me before
um it's not unrealistic there's plenty
of Directors that also write the problem
the easy trap for writer directors is
they can get really self-indulgent
really quick because basically if you're
writing and directing you're losing a
check-and-balance because the idea is
that something is conceptual an idea is
had sometimes by screenwriters sometimes
by a producer sometimes by director it
is given to a professional writer to put
into words and then given into the hands
of a director who knows how to bring it
to life so each step of that is in a way
a bit of a check and balance to be sure
that it's not just self congratulatory
masturbatory you know echo chamber stuff
which writer directors
that can happen that's why I can't
friggin stan jim jarmusch movies and i
think he's one of the most pretentious
people to ever be allowed to shoot a
film and one could argue it was why
episode 1 of Star Wars was so bad
because George Lucas wrote produced and
directed who was gonna tell him no Who
am I
another day another destiny this
never-ending Road to Calvary your name
is no he's not Conde no it's not I want
to be a supervillain Zack unrealistic
not with the right ambition
nicely done Gabe last of Mohicans yes
now obviously I'm older than the movie
my mother named me after the character
from the book but there you go hang on
like jump on back to the discord got to
catch up on a few of these um what is
your opinion on age and relationships
I'm not talking about inappropriate age
differences of of course in terms of
people being under 18 I'm assuming each
partners 18 plus um suspicious and
skeptical of anyone who makes the
argument that age is just a number
because while there's a certain factual
truth to that it's very often used as a
smokescreen for by-and-large older men
to justify having relationship with
women much younger than them and not all
of those are always automatically bad
and I'm not gonna call it a red flag
let's call it a pink flag
whenever I see I'm gonna say age
difference of 15 years or more
especially if you're talking somebody
and their 40s or older and somebody in
their 20s because no matter how old the
soul a person in their 20s has they
don't have the life experience to that
someone much older does and while it
does not automatically make the person
in their forties manipulative it
certainly does put them on uneven
footing because the person in their 20s
is not going to be expected to recognize
all of the warming signs that someone
with more life experience would it puts
the person who is older in an inherent
position of any equitable power simply
by the little by the breadth of their
experience so again without making a
blanket condemnation
I am very skeptical and suspicious is
too strong a word but I am I am cautious
and wary of any relationship that that
has that significant an age gap because
while on paper I can see the arguments
for it shouldn't matter I've also been
around I I've also lived and I've seen
the reality that usually happens when
there is that big in a an age gap and
I'm not gonna ignore the reality because
somebody made a good argument on paper
and the reality is usually very skeevy
see
just gonna say I'm four years older than
my significant other we're both kind of
kind of goofs though well I mean I'm
what a mine I am six months older than
my significant other which I which
actually means I've slightly improved
because with my daughter's mother I was
seven months older which is a faction
will never let me forget because that
makes me the old man ah don't date
someone the same ages your kid I mean
that's I don't want to sound like a
prude but that just kind of makes me go
hey would you like to see Doctor Who in
a different visual format movie
animation telenovela miniseries etc I
would like to see Doctor Who done
animated done well because we've had dr.
who animated stuff and some of it's been
better than others but it's always been
unfailingly low end animation it's been
flash animation or it's been you know
just very rudimentary I would love to
see something doctor who related done
with Disney level animation with that
kind of money with that kind of skill I
would love to see what that looks like
this is what happened to Terry Bollea
Hulk Hogan a lot of things happen to him
let's let's be very frank about that
I want a who's sick Oh Doctor Who circle
I like it see
do you think the master should have
stayed in power I know you asked that I
answered that if doctor who was animated
would you want it internally justified
Oh we've crossed over a dimensional void
into an animator up not really like just
like do it as a special tell you what
the next holiday special whether it is
Christmas or New Year's or Easter or
Halloween I don't care next anime
special do it animated don't even give a
reason just do it they won't but that's
me do you think Martha Jones is
underrated yeah
by and large farts thoughts on dark
comedy depends on where the darkness is
so a little bit like what I talked about
before with maturity dark comedy can be
one of two things it can be dark
conceptually or can be dark super super
officially it can be dark because it is
finding laughs in the bleakness of
existence and the existential dread of
the human condition
or it can be dark because they they
killed somebody gratuitously you know so
it's it's a matter of approach and the
superficial trappings are generally
won't bother me
and I tend to tend to move away from
like if you want a dark comedy like in
my mind a proper doc dark comedy you
should be laughing at and then once it's
done you should be unsettled and my
personal favorite example of that is the
British film for lions which I also
talked about on my list of films that
freaked me out because ideas and
concepts central to that film unnerved
me
to my core it also made me laugh but it
disturbed me deeply
that is impressive dark comedy to me if
they did a Doctor Who Halloween special
could you see the doctor dressed up as
one of his previous selves I mean six
doctors outfit is the most costume like
go with that thoughts on memento love it
that's a great film
I remember you watching in a while
though thanks for your stranger things
review was tentative to season three
after feeling the same way you did about
season two if you didn't like season due
season three a shot don't expect it to
beat season one good but it's good could
you please do more inside them inside
number nine of our series two in three
and they are so much better than series
one ah maybe we'll see has your top ten
Tenth Doctor episodes I mean I'll do
that after I finish up the Tenth Doctor
I'm getting there for Lions was amazing
terrific and I can't confirm I know many
people like that it's so very true to
life which makes it even more dark yeah
yeah pretty much
so been warned sorry is saying sorry I
missed the answer to the question good
answer again so what do you what he'd
asked was if I thought doctor who would
have been better if at the end of series
three the master hadn't been defeated
and he was still controlling earth into
series four I don't know if it would
have been inherently better it would
have been interesting it would have been
a pretty bold choice as long as they
didn't undo what the day says my deus ex
machina the way they actually did in the
show mmm
but um I don't think it would have
automatically been better I like my one
big concern with that ideas it would
have really made it a very terrestrially
bound it would have made the stakes kind
of demand that the doctor stay on earth
until it was dealt with and I don't like
Doctor Who and it feels overly tied to
this planet oh I'm off and adventuring
so that would be my issue with that
concept
I tend to trust your taste I don't see
everything so apart from Doctor Who and
stranger things what do you recommend
giving a shot to if you haven't seen
legends of tomorrow recommend that
isolate to get to the latest season but
I've had a ton of fun with that show
pitch of Doctor Who episode I don't have
something off the top my head well then
I gotta get back to the discord if I'm
gonna wrap this up on time which I
probably won't
um what's your favorite bad movie or
show I mean my favorite bad movies
probably the Masters of the Universe
moon with Dolph Lundgren it's not good
but I love the heck out of it I'm gonna
show that I'm not sure there's any shows
that I like that I would call bad shows
though I have a hard time I have said
before the so bad it's good thing I most
of the time doesn't appeal to me so the
idea of like sticking on long term for a
show like let's see I think that might
have been it are you interested in the
new The Shining movie the sequel coming
out I mean has a bit of a morbid
curiosity sequel that's better than the
original I mean that used to be a trick
question a tricky question but it's not
now in the age of superhero movies
because spider-man 2x2 Dark Knight you
know it's it's there's a lot more
options available now and I think that
covers all the discord awesome sweet did
you watch the actual Constantine TV show
I did it was okay
I think the problem with it is it was
very much stuck in a format that was out
of date it felt like it was trying to
stick to the format of things like Buffy
or house or you know very like here's
this character and they'll have a case
to solve er you know a demon to deal
with every episode like that was an
outmoded way of telling these kinds of
stories so excuse me I think that was a
fairly big part of why didn't do
even though Matt Ryan was very good in
the part and I'm glad he's still playing
but like show itself honestly wasn't
great because it's its format felt both
outdated and safe that said see the
animated City of demons cuz it's amazing
I give you of curse of fatal death but
what is more funny is that it was
written by Steven Moffat who made the
Doctor Who series later I mean it is
especially with all the parallels you
can draw with the jokes he made and
things that he would actually then do
later it's actually kind of funny would
you be interested in Sherlock series 5
revealing that revealed that San Diego
comic-con even though it probably will
never happen Sherlock series 4 was so
bad that I kinda don't want them to do
any more like the second episode of
series 4 was great but that first one
and that last one especially were so bad
so monumentally bad that like I just
like leave it alone I don't trust this
creative team to redeem it and I don't
want them to dig the hole any deeper
just remember Daleks do not have noses
ha ha ha
I'm popular opinion I find Sherlock to
be boring the thing is I feel like it's
actually becoming a little bit of a
popular opinion to say that Sherlock was
never good which I think happens rather
often in shows that end badly that
people started to say I was never that
good in the first place because they're
trying to basically reconcile the fact
that something they loved ended so
poorly I think we're gonna see that with
Game of Thrones too you know people
starting to make arguments like and you
know you're already seeing it oh really
wasn't good after season four it's some
people like no was it ever that good in
the first place it's it's a defense
mechanism to not to want to it's easier
it's softer on your ego to go back and
believe oh was never that good then to
accept that you were invested and it let
you down because you know that's that's
a more complicated thing to wrap your
head around
think I'm gonna wrap it up relatively
soon how do you rate Moffat as a writer
I always feel that as a lifelong Who fan
it's amazing to have new villains
written into the lore which hadn't
appeared for decades um I like Moffat
better as an episode writer than a
showrunner but as a writer he is capable
of being very very clever but he's also
capable of disappearing completely up
his own butt
how's he did with hell-bent as he did
with the final problem you know he I
think the problem is that he knows he's
a clever writer and that can honestly be
a massive detriment because if no matter
how clever you are if you think you're
clever then you get cocky in your ideas
and you don't vet them the way you
should I mean it's even worse if you
think clever and you're not but if you
think you're clever even if you are
eventually that bites you in the butt
because not every idea you have is gonna
be great but if you've bought into your
own myth which I think Moffat has then
you assume all your ideas are good and
you don't put them under the scrutiny
that they need so it's kind of the same
issue I have with Garth Ennis as a
writer I was that before I think the
man's about seventy percent as clever as
he thinks he is so I am actually gonna
wrap it up I think folks cuz I feel bad
about cuz I actually have jumped jumped
up to what might be one of the highest
number of people watching the live
stream I've had but like I said I have
got so much editing to do tonight Oh God
so I need I need to get on that
- clever by half and at least by half in
some cases I also think he got spread
way too thin but the legacy of inventing
the weeping angels is his achievement I
mean look even up until the very end of
his run he was still doing good work
just not always consistently and when he
got stuffand old and he got really self
indulgent her girl Clara her hell been
hmm
who said that I didn't say that alright
so I'm gonna wrap it up there oh wow
last minute thank you very much thank
you so much for everything
well thank you I I don't I don't push to
do hard but like I I am at a point where
like the the patreon and you know things
dropped in to the livestream or whatever
they are actually helping me pay my
bills because I I would be in deep
trouble without them I've got my goals
covered let me be clear like I'm not in
dire straits it's not a like I'm in
trouble but like this stuff helps and
you're all amazing and I hope you have
hope you have a really great rest of
your week
so we'll wrap it up there folks and I
want you to remember you are beautiful
you are loved you are valid you are the
council and I'm just drinking water